let's go straight to the phones let's go
to clint in tuscaloosa alabama
my man clint how are we doing doing
great dr dalony how are you sir i'm
doing good all right so let's go ahead
and be honest with the audience here
i know you clint is that true yes that
is true
all right so i knew you as a
undergraduate student
as a graduate student and you worked for
one of my departments at one point at
one of the universities that we both
uh worked for and then attended is that
right
that's correct yes sir so is it okay
stop saying sir and all that i know
you're from texas and you're in alabama
so
you've got double double south there but
can we just get it out of the way that i
was pretty much the greatest boss you've
ever had and
probably am ever gonna have oh greatest
uh
no you were yeah i mean you're the
reason why i'm actually in the field of
higher education so watching you
at abilene christian and kind of grow in
your career path
is just outstanding and so you've kind
of been a role model to me
and to many other i'm sure other
undergraduates
who attended the university um it's just
been a blessing so
thank you i thank you number one number
two if you've noticed i've since left
higher education so we can talk after
the show
and number three i will send you a check
directly to your inbox so i appreciate
you uh i think the kids are using venmo
these today this
these days and so i'll figure that out
how that works
i actually clint had to
i had to text my wife last night to have
her venmo somebody something yesterday
and i actually asked james if he could
burn me a cd and he looked at me as
though
i had asked him hey can you help me
repair my covered wagon
and that's not that's not a lie i want
all the
tobii ingway cds and evidently they're
not see these are mp3s that's not what
you called clint
so what's up how are we doing man look
man i am doing
you know very well uh the reason why i
wanted to reach out to you as i've been
watching your youtube videos and
you give you know great advice for you
know people that i've uh you know i've
watched several videos i've been like
wow that's great i write it down
and i've been practicing it one that you
know i i struggle the most with however
is
having a short temper and this is
something that
is generational in my family so all the
coulter
man i just shouted out my last name
there
but all of the men in my family they
basically
have this like short temper and i don't
know if it just passes along or passes
on
my cousins who are male they have it my
my brother he has it not as bad as i
think
what i have and it has just stemmed from
since i was a little kid i mean i can
remember punching a
actually kicking a hole in a wall
because i was losing a video game with
my brother
so things like that and it was all
because
you know and i witnessed my father do it
i'm just having a short temper i
witnessed my grandfather having a short
temper
you know he was riding a horse one time
and he was actually trying to break the
horse and
i was outside i was young i was like
papa come on inside you know food's
ready and he didn't hear me so i kept
yelling his name
and then he yelled back i mean very
angrily and kind of like said some word
choice words
that i probably shouldn't repeat over
the year and so you know and i broke
down and was like oh my gosh you know
you know he hates me um and that
happened to my with my dad too at times
um and most recent uh yeah do you have
little kids now clint
i have i have a little girl now and uh
she's about five months and i don't want
to
bring that into my family i don't want
her to have see her father like man my
dad and when he gets mad he gets
mad like i don't want that i want to
be someone where my little girl who
grows up can look at her father and be
like you know when my dad would get
upset or mad he just kind of keeps it to
himself he doesn't yell he doesn't
scream he just kind of
you know is able to you know work
through
the anger and that's where i'm trying to
get out of how can i work through this
anger
um if you want me to give you examples i
can do that well let's
let's do this um first
i wanna applaud you for looking into the
eyes
of a baby girl and saying no more
that this is i'm third generation short
temper
i'm third generation adult temper
tantrum
and this stops with me and there's a
whole bunch of men clint
across the country who have got to take
that sort of responsibility with who
they are
things that are going on in you know
automated responses that they have in
their hearts and minds
and that's the only way we're gonna fix
the messes that we are in right now
and so dude high five to you i'd hug you
if you were sitting here
um i'm proud of you okay so give me an
example what's the latest one
um the latest one was with actually my
father
and it was about two weeks ago
i've lived out here in tuscaloosa for
about three years
and before that i lived out in wichita
falls which was just a couple hours
north from where my family lives and
i lived there for about three years and
during that time
i only saw my dad once he only came out
and visited me
one time and the majority of the time he
was like well you and your wife y'all
need to come down and visit us y'all
need to come see us and we did
often um because we were just a couple
hours but
anytime i would bring up why don't you
come up and see us there was always an
excuse behind it well we can't do that
well you know financially we're not able
to afford it
well you know we're just not able to
because this this and that
and so i kind of just let it go
but now that i have a little girl and
she was born this summer
um i've reached out to my dad a couple
times like hey when you would would you
be able to come out
and it's a little difficult of course
with kovid and of course now he has some
health concerns um but
uh it's about a 10 hour drive from
dallas to
tuscaloosa and we've made the trip about
twice a year
and he won't come see you now
exactly and so so the conversation was
essentially i just told him and he has
another uh
he has a he has a grandson and they live
close to home and he sees him
quite often a lot and so
so in your heart in your head i can
guess where this is going in your head
your dad doesn't care about your
daughter that much your dad doesn't care
about because if he did he would do
these things
right he doesn't care about your new
marriage
he didn't care about your new job you
don't want to come see how successful
his young son is doing
um all these all these
almost moral or character issues are
piled up into
these actions that your dad is not
taking all right or aren't
taking which is he's not coming to see
you he's not coming to see his name
right right right and so he'll go ahead
so you you did you grown man blow up on
him or grown man temper tantrum him
essentially uh yeah so i asked them the
question
or i just basically told them in a very
calm manner i was like look you know
this is how i'm feeling like i feel that
if the roles were reversed
and your uh grandson had lived 10 hours
away that you and
you and my stepmom would have driven out
and visited
and when i had said that of course i was
like this is just how i
feel china's son telling his dad hey
look this stuff hill
and that is when he blew up on me
like that short temper just kicked in
and he started yelling over the phone
which i do not respond very well so if
i'm being yelled at
i typically don't have a very good
response to it and so i
yell back and we have this
yelling back and forth and then we just
hang up the phone
and then we text back and forth
um and it ended up where a couple days
later was like i'm sorry in a text
message i'm sorry i'm sorry dude love
you love you
and that was it and so now i'm at the
point where i'm just like
you know i'm not even going to ever ask
him
to come and visit because i know where
it would lead
sure all right so here here we go clint
you ready
i'm ready here's a couple of things some
of them are easy
all of this is simple and all of this is
hard
okay simple doesn't mean it's not gonna
be hard work okay
so the first thing is this anger is a
gift
as rage against the machine eloquently
said
um anger just points you towards things
that you care about
and so in that little exchange your dad
cares about his son he cares about his
son's approval
he cares about his son's um
his son's um like you know
approval of his job as a dad his
approval of his
his his role as a good man right someone
who'd go visit his
young child et cetera et cetera um
my guess is your dad doesn't have a
graduate degree is that fair
correct right so you've got this son and
you've got this
educated son now right so there's all
these barriers between you and old man
and anger points towards something he
cares about anger points towards
something you care about
you want your daughter to experience a
grandparent right her grandparents you
want your daughter to
experience her dad her granddad because
you love him and he's probably a fun
cool guy when you got him hanging out
and having a good
time and anger points towards justice
this is the way this is supposed to be
right so all those things are good where
it's not good
is when anger takes over and you and
your grown dad start throwing crayons at
each other
right and then you take it offline or
literally take it online if you will
and continue um you know
thumb warning each other right on on the
internets on the iphones so here's what
i want you to do to break this curse and
it is not
genetic it's not a wiring you're not
predestined to always have a short
temper
this is something you learned and was
modeled for you
you may have some gasoline and matches
in your basement right which
you may have a genetic disposition
towards x y and z
that's not a pass and i don't care about
that stuff
every time you lose your temper it's a
choice it's a decision
and so what i want you to do is
the next time you get angry the next
time you feel that thing
frustrating you i want you to
think of if you've got one it's even
better i'm taking this from terrence
real
if you've got a picture of your dad i
want you to carry it with you in your
wallet or in your pocket
and every time you get mad i want you to
pull that picture out
and i want you to look at it and i want
you to
say out loud i am going to throw a
temper tantrum
in honor of you instead of
loving my daughter
because every time you throw a temper
tantrum it is a choice
to bring tension and pain into the life
of your daughter
it's to bring gasoline and fire into the
house
of a little one in a young marriage of
which your daughter will absorb that
tension
and make it her fault and spend her
lifetime trying to solve it
which will then she will be modeled a
great solution to this
is short intermittent outbursts nuclear
bombs that just get dropped along
a a living room and
thus it passes to another generation
right and so every time you choose to
snap to yell to slam something to
kick something to bite back at somebody
i want you to say and that's for you dad
there you go i chose to high five you
instead of
honoring my wife instead of
being a controlled mature
grown man doesn't mean i'm not going to
get angry doesn't mean i'm not going to
get really frustrated
i chose dad to give you a shout out
instead of
modeling for my daughter what a healthy
well whole dad looks like
what a healthy well whole marriage looks
like
and here's the thing you're gonna have
to learn this you have to practice it
but i've seen stories where
it can be healed literally overnight
with the idea that i'm not doing this
because
it's going to solve anything because it
never solves anything
i'm not doing this because i can't
control it because that's bullcrap
it is an homage it's a high five to the
past
this one's for you old man and what i'm
gonna challenge you
is to stop high-fiving your dad and
start
hugging and loving your daughter start
hugging
and loving your wife start hugging and
loving those
hundreds of students you've been put in
charge of start respecting
and honoring the folks that you work for
at whatever college and university
you're gonna work for
go forward go that way and clint
it's such an honor and a blessing to
talk to you again we haven't talked in a
decade
because you're one of those guys that's
turning to face the forest fire the one
that's been raging generationally
and you're going to stand it down and it
ends with you and it ends with you
saying
either i'm going to continue to high
five old man or i'm going to
connect with my wife and my daughter and
it's that simple
you're going to fail you're going to be
graceful with yourself you're gonna have
to be compassionate with yourself
um here's the thing while we're here
let's just i wanna talk about this real
quick
because in clint this is for you it kind
of lines up perfectly almost
accidentally here
as you transition this from being a
third or fourth generation
anger head addicted to outburst grown up
temper tamp drum thrower if you will
as you transition this you're gonna have
to be graceful with yourself you're
gonna have to forgive yourself
and self-forgiveness is an absolutely
essential
part of living and growing up and we are
terrible at it
y'all heard me say this over and over we
so often talk to ourselves in a way that
we would
never let somebody else talk to somebody
else
we forgive people around us if we're
mature grown-up adults not if we're
children
wearing adult clothes but we forgive
people for hurting us
we forgive parents for hurting us we
forgive
politicians for screwing up we forgive
people for all sorts of things
but man we suck at forgiving ourselves
we're terrible at it in fact
this weekend um or this week
recently uh peter tia he's got a podcast
called the drive
after you listen to mine listen to his
it's incredible he just interviewed
um kristen neifer kristen neefs
i think that's her name kristen neese
she is the
expert on self-compassion you have to
talk to yourself in a way
that is honoring and lovely
and respectful and forgiving self-con
forgiveness is a choice to extend
love and compassion and kindness to
yourself right
it's when you have a really rough day
and you eat something you probably
shouldn't have eaten you know it's going
to make you feel bad like the other day
on the 12 hour thanksgiving drive
when i ate half a bag of sandwich
cookies i knew that wasn't great
and that next morning when i woke up
feeling like feeling hungover and all i
had was junk food
i was compassion myself i had to forgive
myself hey that wasn't good for me for
my body for my parenting
but it happened wouldn't my best self
let's go be better today
right unforgiveness prevents you from
living in the present and expecting good
things in the future
because you condemn yourself you
sentence yourself to some sort of
punishment that just goes on
indefinitely
stop stop unforgiveness is
costly the cost of unforgiveness is your
integrity your identity your capacity to
give and receive
love it's a lie to yourself
so this is for clint this is for
everyone listening to this
if you're trying to change behaviors as
we get into the new year and you are
trying to set
new goals and new year's resolutions or
you're doing
hard things like changing generational
trauma like clint's trying to do
you're going to stumble and you're going
to fall if you're just trying to be a
dad just a regular old humdrum
run-of-the-mill dad or a mom you're
going to stumble
right you're going to stumble so be
graceful with yourself be kind to
yourself
forgive yourself and if you can't do it
by yourself get somebody that
will walk alongside you get a good
friend that will say
i forgive you so you should too